ow [ __ ] my hand howdy Gomez mine is
where bad best weapon I want that [ __ ]
I think someone wrote in the comments
saying I need to punish more people me I
don't [ __ ] know here we go
I'm I'm [ __ ] this is actually holy [ __ ]
what is that cracking sound no no what
is that sound
what is going on in here ha ha ha ok ha
it's so [ __ ] dark yet super late
right now
I usually don't play that late it's just
that I'm really oh thank god a baseball
bat ah ok no no no no what the hell
happen what are you what are you what
are you what are you what are you what
are you what I never right face Oh what
the hell is wrong with our latest data
ah just died what if you're dying right
right
why don't you die right oh [ __ ] you
track me right what do you want
where is C I kick you ha ha
[ __ ] why don't you die [ __ ] why don't
you die where's your friend
watch your is [ __ ] right there [ __ ] left
nut but job on a nap on twice
stay down your [ __ ] stayed up if
boot cows here to stay down you stay
down stay down
that's right boot get out that's oh [ __ ]
what what [ __ ] you and [ __ ] your mama no
I'm sorry I'm sorry about your mom let's
not bring our mothers Internet rape and
petty boot not now he's not dead yet
ok all right after work what are you
[ __ ] mocha it getting so dark you
probably can't even see my [ __ ] face
red start from last say penis
better if I do like this [ __ ] Africa
Mike Arouca maka that come on Mia
come on me Eric comprends what I'll be
angry this is a song alright it's
fighting down baseball bat in time all
right break it up
back it up just do it oh [ __ ] you [ __ ]
your mama and bite your nipples mm I'll
twist activate stay down stay the [ __ ]
down
I know there's more of you I know there
is more of you I know for a [ __ ] fact
because I played this long enough there
you are oh oh
stay where's Dana [ __ ] all of you [ __ ]
all of you [ __ ] all that oh oh well uh I
mean oh [ __ ] I gotta come up at well I
guess they didn't MIT what's that face
oh god I can't think of anything you've
breath write in the comments and then
yeah I usually come up with something in
the end and I just [ __ ] draw a blank
I guess they did and have this as their
home base [ __ ] that was horrible all
right ha ha where the hell am I going
why am i throwing things that is rude
all right well maybe over here all right
yeah let's check out this door it
doesn't have it handles that's not gonna
wear I migrated right wind out loud no I
said okay maybe here
doesn't do much for me this door should
work hi those [ __ ] what is this oh
it's tears cool I see the stars
what is this a note well boot it if you
don't like it then you should have put a
boot on it if you like it and you share
the product
alright BAM you don't like it then you
showed you put your boobs in it yeah
you don't like a dandy bear to poop sing
with me petty happy I like alright what
the [ __ ] am i doing
alright we're all the [ __ ] I was told
specifically there would be I get to
shoot people now I was kind of liking
bass holding drink well this is
inappropriate yeah yeah I just drink
around the Malka huh because I laying on
the street because I'm badass like that
and I pick up shotguns yeah yeah why
oh gosh I'm badass [ __ ] this game is
stupid for doing that I'm just saying
all right who wants some of my tango
nests I know I know
hey hey hey oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] nothing
this is not loud alright bamm-bamm Oh
drug Blanca penis BAM that's how I roll
scan for sperm
okay what it's shooting me stop shooting
me it's not Call of Duty
all right get him I am stupid Stepan
scan for sperm all right now claim uh
okay my guys I go over here [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you bye daddy Gaga Lady Gaga oh
don't shoot him in the dick hey me too
alright thank you for that scan for
sperm shut up shut up shut up shut up
shut up shut up I don't know what
happened shut up shut up shut up and
stop worried I mean
stop worrying [ __ ] I never worry I scan
for him okay I need to stop clicking
that bottom yes yes yes yes yes
everything is okay hey everything's
alright
beat apart on the act as your television
boom I missed it that's okay that's okay
that's okay
step aside there we got alright there's
someone here I'm sure he's not gonna
come alive or anything like that
I played enough horror games to know
what's gonna happen
Rosa come here oh is that what do you
got a dead body okay let's try and make
an ID all right
examine what uh-huh yeah you are a male
uh-huh and evidence up ripped sweats ah
and a badge
uh-huh that is very interesting can you
stop doing that please poor [ __ ] job
why should have a pity what I'm sorry
oh he is only wearing a ship
I think someone tickle limb did that rip
all right scan all this [ __ ]
stop saying a port BAM
well happy I have to do everything
how's the body being moved uh probably
because there's no [ __ ] blood here
it's only a bit of poo all right uh yes
all right cool ah [ __ ] I gotta follow
that don't I
where is it I can't walk around oh I can
or can't I I should be able to slip
through this shed
this is dis redonkulous well yes the
[ __ ] body has been moved what do you
want for me yes ah yeah [ __ ] what woman
Mormon don't test me right now woman yes
yes it has [ __ ] boomer yes yes but
lead you to the actual crimes
perhaps yeah probably most [ __ ]
likely I would say but yeah now everyone
has different tastes about can I please
pass here thank you thank you couch for
stepping aside now what a pity
thank you catch your breath all right
what happened to the ambience I don't
like this a B ins should not just shut
up itself like that someone moaning over
here
exit how nice huh doesn't work this game
is so [ __ ] dark darker than the
darkest pit what are you doing who are
you coming from where well sorry I mean
I'm not sorry left nipple
quadruple nipple kick him right right
come on
he is dead
shut up shut up don't kill me don't kill
me don't kill me I have no help okay it
regenerated
alright we're fine we are fine Kruger
Hooper
I hear you know it's not Jesus it's not
Jesus Jesus would not do this to me
yes toilet lid yes
let's go toilet let Barry I took a lot
of [ __ ] to get here
I know toilet gets I uh may totally Len
all right what is that soured 0-3 uh all
right I need to go in here I guess it's
a locked no no no no no no no uh-uh
shut up shut up it's another toilet I
say uh get him toilet lid blockage ha ha
no no get a mode [ __ ] you but please
reconnect computer died son of a barrel
all right I think that's about time for
me bread because I don't [ __ ] know
let me see I messed up today wait no
signal are you drunk I'll buy that but I
all right that's it form a breast like a
baby zoondy i subscribe combat Brad
today I need to change batteries so
but you [ __ ] mouth everywhere I think